[Music]
ed is with us in pensacola florida hi ed
how are you
hey dave i'm doing good thank you good i
can't help
uh my question is about the the last
couple days the c the center for disease
control you know uh
extending the moratorium on uh evictions
and um
i you know i was listening to the news
and normally the news guy he's
he's pretty good but he was kind of um
inflammatory i guess yesterday evening
or saying that that this is leading
toward the government uh
trying to seize your property uh
are you any kind of worried about that
no
okay there's too many guns in america
they're not seizing our property it's
okay
you're gonna be fine oh
it's not gonna okay all right no we're
not that's not gonna happen that's just
that's just people carrying on on the
news
um and let me add to that that the cdc
does not have the power to enforce the
moratorium it is a suggested moratorium
there are no federal laws that allow
uh the federal government to interfere
in individual property rights state by
state the only thing they can do is go
through any federal programs that are
there to enforce them now they can
enforce them on federally funded
tenants and things like that but they
cannot enforce that so the cdc is a
suggested moratorium and it's up to
florida as to whether they enforce it or
not as a state the state of tennessee
has not enforced it we had a short
period of time in the state of tennessee
last summer where the uh the local
supreme court made a ruling that there
was a temporary moratorium for two
months
in the at the height of kovid last
summer
on evictions and um i actually had one
eviction on one of our properties
pending during that time i had a [ __ ]
that was beating his wife and she left
and we're trying to throw him out
because obviously we don't do business
with twerps like that
um and we couldn't get him out for that
two months but once the two-month uh
eviction
uh there was an injunction against
eviction evictions in the state of
tennessee for that period of time now i
do not know state by state who currently
has
an eviction
uh moratorium or an eviction injunction
placed and i i would be shocked to hear
that in desantis's florida
that there is one
but i don't think you've got one in
place there you can check with a local
attorney if you want the does your
evictions and ask and find out what
what's really going on because it's
what controls property rights is not
federal law it's state law
and so that's the point of the
discussion so the cdc does not have the
power
to do that under law and so their
moratorium is more of a suggestion
just like they're suggesting people wear
masks
and we're looking i'm looking in the
lobby at 60 people none of which have a
mask on so that's how much we care about
the cdc right
so yeah and so that you know it's just
you know it's a matter of we've all kind
of gotten disgusted with these twerps
and they're they're throwing their power
around all over the place and it doesn't
work now so but they can do a lot of
things locally uh you know if the local
legislature passes it your state
legislature passes it now you've got
property right issues
but for instance the i'll give you
another example ed
the right of imminent domain
where pr where the government takes
property for the good of the community
for instance a highway is coming through
and they take a piece of your daddy's
farm
or whatever they take that house or
something like that because of the
highway rights
uh that's imminent domain
that is all state law it is not federal
law
so were you to argue with the
municipality that was doing that or the
state that was doing that you would
argue that in state court not federal
court
and so because again all private
property rights issues
are not federal
uh and so that's where
uh stuff like executive orders coming
out of dc
uh sometimes don't have any teeth in
them
they're more of a mere suggestion which
is really what the cdc's thing is here
so you look it up i'm not an attorney i
got a whole bunch of real estate though
and i'm zero worried about this in the
state of tennessee now if i lived in new
york city i'd be real worried about it
because apparently they're taking over
everything up there i don't know what
they're doing but uh lost their dadgum
minds
but uh uh but you know
you know all of us living in these uh in
between states where mostly sanity is
still existing
you know we're not seeing that kind of
thing and i think you're right i think
your news guy was inflammatory